За два роки повноцінної роботи НАБУ
і Спеціалізованої антикорупційної прокуратури
українці не раз чули про гучні корупційні справи
і затримання. Однак у багатьох випадках
до судового вироку справа ще не дійшла.
А подекуди
фігурантів справи суди відпускали на волю
на час розслідування, після чого деякі
втікали за кордон. У НАБУ це пояснюють
перш за все відсутністю антикорупційних судів,
роль яких нині виконують нереформовані суди.
Ось перелік найбільш гучних корупційних справ,
не доведених до завершення.
Останній корупційний скандал пов'язаний
із заступником міністра оборони Ігорем Павловським
та главою департаменту держзакупівель відомства
Володимирем Гулевичем.
НАБУ підозрює їх обох у розтраті
майже 150 мільйонів гривень
при закупівлі палива для потреб армії.
Попри клопотання НАБУ про затримання,
суд відпустив обох під домашній арешт.
Виявлення махінацій з продажем
видобутого державою газу
стало однією з найбільших корупційних справ
минулого року. В організації цих оборудок
звинуватили нардепа Олександра Онищенка.
НАБУ оприлюднило всі деталі схеми,
яка нібито завдала державі збитків
на 3 мільярди гривень. Низку учасників схеми
правоохоронці затримали, але сам Онищенко
встиг втекти до Лондона, поки Генпрокуратура
готувала подання про зняття з нього
недоторканності.
Епопея з затриманням голови
Державної фіскальної служби Романа Насірова,
який то раптово хворів, то знову одужував,
привернула увагу багатьох українців.
НАБУ звинуватило його у зловживанні
службовим становищем та розкраданням
державних коштів на суму
більше двох мільярдів гривень.
Слідство вважає, що Насіров,
діючи в інтересах депутата Онищенка,
надавав низці підприємств можливість
податкових зобов’язань у розстрочку.
На час слідства Насіров вийшов з-за ґрат,
заплативши заставу.
У червні цьогоріч НАБУ розкрило
схему з видобутку бурштину, до якої причетні
народні депутати від правлячої коаліції -
Борислав Розенблат та Максим Поляков. Згідно зі схемою,
під виглядом рекультивації у Житомирській області
планувався фактичний видобуток бурштину
і надалі його реалізація
через офшорну фірму, засновниця якої -
сестра депутата Розенблата.
Сума хабарів, отриманих у цій справі,
сягає 300 тисяч гривень.
Верховна Рада дозволила
притягнути до відповідальності обох депутатів,
але не дала дозволу затримувати чи арештовувати
народних обранців. Вони й досі
вільно ходять до парламенту.
Улітку 2016 року розгорівся ще один
гучний корупційний скандал -
навколо так званої "чорної бухгалтерії Партії регіонів".
Колишній заступник голови СБУ Віктор Трепак
заявив, що передав до НАБУ
приховану бухгалтерію Партії Регіонів.
В ній містяться дані про незаконні платежі
і підкуп чиновників на понад 2 мільярди гривень.
У документах були прізвища топ-чиновників
та політиків, які начебто отримували хабарі.
Серед них - екс-керівник виборчої кампанії
Дональда Трампа Пол Манафорт і
голова Центрвиборчкому Михайло Охендовський.
Останнього суд відпустив
під особисте зобов'язання.
Він досі залишається на своїй посаді.